hello everyone and welcome to a really
nice game that was uh
suggested to me numerous times over the
uh last two days uh it's
the entire uh league of legends cloud9
team versus andrew tang
uh most of you know him as the penguin
and here i don't uh
i don't uh really have all that much
room here to fit all five of them but
these are the gentlemen that
participated in this event there you
have it
uh all of them playing against andrew
and andrew is playing blindfold so it's
um it wouldn't really make sense for
them to play against andrew without
andrew being blindfold so you know
to even the even the field a little bit
uh so it's quite the game and uh
when when the people first started
sending me this i thought oh it's just
penguin you know having his way with
them but then when i actually checked
out the game it's
actually a pretty high quality game so
uh without further ado let's check it
out and let's see
how much problems were they able to
cause to to andrew here
so uh cloud9 with the white pieces opens
with
e4 uh we have e5 knight to f3 knight to
c6
and they go for the royal lopez bishop
to b5 is on the board
and g6 andrew goes for this real lopez
fiance defense which is a bit
rarer and hopes to throw them off guard
with knight the c3
uh and the bishop to g7 fiance the
bishop castles and now
knight g to e7 preparing the castle
we have d3 and andrew now castles bishop
to g5
makes sense uh just continue developing
your pieces
uh but here in this case maybe bishop to
g5 is a bit too optimistic because you
you run into blacks uh h5
h6 and g5 but okay it's not all that big
of a deal we have h6 by andrew
and now there are some games in the
database where bishop captures on e7 was
played where bishop to e3 was played
bishop to d2 also exist as a move
but the move cloud9 play is a new move
so as of uh
move uh eight we have a completely new
game and here they played bishop
captures on c6
and this is uh something you don't
usually do because
you can just move your bishop and you
keep the bishop pair but here you
give up your light square bishop
voluntarily and that
oh that's something you don't uh well
want to do
all that all that often so here andrew
really started thinking and
he uh in the end he decided to capture
the light square bishop first he played
the
b captures in c6 even though h captures
and g5 is also fine but okay b captures
in c6
bishop to h4 and now d6 just preparing
to develop the light square bishop as
well
and they continue development with queen
to d2
so now they have to bring the rooks into
the game and figure out what they're
going to do on the king side against
those pawns so here
g5 clearing the g6 square for this
knight the knight can then also come to
f4 if needed
bishop to g3 and now uh bishop to g4 so
just
nicely developing pieces to natural
squares and
well they don't want to allow bishop
captures on f3 because then they're
going to have to mess up their
king side so in instead of going knights
to e1 maybe preparing f3
and such they decided to sacrifice the
knight for two pieces uh for two pawns
and they played knight captures on g5
and okay
uh knight for two pawns that's you know
almost never a problem h captures queen
captures
and now the bishop is under attack
andrew needs to react to this and then
they have to figure out how to continue
the attack because you've sacrificed the
peace you should attack something
the problem is it's very hard to bring
more pieces into the attack you can't
really
uh bring the knight into the attack all
of these squares are covered by any
response uh
he's not gonna allow you to push any of
the pawns all the way up the board
and how are you how are you bringing the
rook into the game okay maybe f4
captures and there may be
doubling up rooks here but that's a lot
of moves and andrew can't really
uh you know just uh do do nothing so
here
andrew goes back bishop to d7 and now
f4 and here they already uh started
celebrating a little
saying that how they will checkmate the
penguin uh
and yes if you allow white to simply
double rooks here prepare some sort of
an attack
could get ugly however andrew goes for
f6 he kicks away their queen
quinta h5 and now immediately queen to
e8 he offers a queen trade
and uh so far andrew's been playing the
absolute top moves
even though it's a completely new
position and he is playing blindfold so
very very impressive stuff we have queen
back to e2
and now even f5 grabbing more space and
opening up some lines here he wants to
trade all uh trade all of this
and then uh start start trading pieces
so here we have
f captures on e5 uh uh and now
d characters on e5 we have e captures on
f5 knight captures on f5 and now
rook 8 to e1 uh bringing the other rook
into the game and now all of the pieces
are fully developed so what do you do
here the e5 pawn is under attack three
times by the bishop queen and rook
so andrew moves the queen queen to g6
so now he's preparing rook eight to e8
and he's saying
uh it would not be wise to capture this
pawn maybe
maybe play something else but that's
exactly what they do they play bishop
captures on e5
and allow this very nasty pin a rook
eight to e8 but now
uh andrew when he uh when he was
thinking about all of this he for
he foresaw the d4 move that uh kind of
defends the bishop but it it doesn't
really defend the bishop so they find
d4 they defend the bishop and andrew was
very very impressed by this move as it's
not an easy move to find you have to
calculate a lot of lines to play this
move uh
and here the problem is andrew was
thinking of knight captures on d4 when
he first considered the idea because
of course bishop captures is impossible
the the queen would hang
however there is this uh knight captures
queen to c for
check and then you kind of pick up the
knight here but the problem is
you have the uh queen to e6 and now
yeah it doesn't matter that the queen
can keep a pick up the knight here
because if captures then bishop captures
and black is just winning with uh with a
much superior position
so here you wouldn't really have
anything better than for example rook
captures an f8 rook captures and now
again
there's not not much to be done here so
you would have to uh either trade queens
or
i don't know play this but it's not uh
not a lot of fun because
here andrew has first rook to f5 and
that's the problem he adds another
attacker into the game
uh and if the bishop moves then just
queen captures and e1 is checkmate
but all of this is incredibly difficult
to find but it's not
uh it's not um unnecessary to find it
because andrew finds
rook to f7 and this is also the engine
stop recommendation
and he says what do you play now so here
they play
queen to c4 of course uh immediately
going for this
for this pin and now uh now the the
bishop can definitely move but now comes
knight to d6 and now everything is under
attack the bishop is still under attack
the rook is under attack the queen is
under attack and they either move the
queen but it's not
that easy if you offer a queen trade
bishop f5 and it's a
pretty pretty hard position to play if
the queens get traded off
uh we already said that black's position
is uh is just better
so uh instead after knight to d6 they
played bishop captures on d6 they
decided to trade here
and now we have rook captures on e1 we
rook capture 71 and now c captures on d6
and now as the rook is still pinned they
go for rook to e7 but it's a
it's an incredibly difficult position to
play because they're down a piece
uh if they weren't down a piece of
course it would be a much better
position for them but
they sacrificed for the attack and the
attack never came
so here uh andrew has to decide whether
he captures on d4 to try and get the
queen away from the
uh of the defense of the rook or to play
d5 which works
just as well so the queen is under
attack now also the rook is hanging and
there doesn't appear to be uh all that
great of a move here so
what do you what do you play here uh we
have uh knight
captures on d5 and this is just awesome
here um
i think they were they were kind of
hoping that blindfold penguin falls into
a trap because
if for example the rook is captured it's
checkmate in two
also uh could be a nice target practice
for you feel free to pause the video and
try to spot a checkmate in two
while i give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on
not grabbing the rook well this also
wins the game it's not a mating two
uh and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's knight to f6
nice double check here uh so the king is
in check and it doesn't matter if you go
here or here the knight is needed here
to cover the h
the h7 square so the king cannot escape
and now wherever we go king
h8 or f8 uh results in queen to g8
checkmate so here uh when they played
knight captures on d5 they were in fact
incredibly close to checkmating penguin
but he just laughed
in their face uh metaphorically and
played c
captures on b5 queen captures on d5 and
now
bishop captures on d4 with check trying
to get the queen away from the
uh from pinning this rook so the rook on
e7 can be captured
they played king h1 and now quinta e6
again andrew
uh was very happy with himself that he
finds another trick
uh because uh the bishop cannot be
captured and the queens cannot be traded
because if the queens are traded just uh
capturing the queen and you don't really
have anything you're just down
material too much and if you do
something else
after this queen move if you capture
with the rook then again it's just
rook to f1 checkmate so that's not
possible and also capturing the bishop
is not possible because now rook to f1
check
and you just win queen g1 captures
captures and you pick up
the de rook on e7 so
none of the tricks work for them but
that's of course what what andrew was so
happy when he set up with queen to e6
so they go queen captures an e6 but now
they have
just uh two little material we have
bishop captures
rook captures on f7 we have king
captures and now
b3 and now it's very instructive how
andrew even though he's playing
blindfold he of course
keeps track of everything and he just
plays the absolute quickest move of uh
quickest finds the absolute quickest way
of how to dealing with
with black's final white's final
resistance so
bishop to f1 f5 he goes after the pawns
here
c4 it was funny because someone on the
team actually uh touched uh kind of the
the g
pawn here uh because
if you move the g pawn then this is just
instant checkmate so you can't really do
that
uh so after bishop to f5 f5 we have c4
and now bishop to b1 just going after
the pawns and
there is no way to defend this a3 we
have bishop to a2
now there's no point in pushing because
you lose the pawn here so g4 was played
but now bishop captures on b3 we have
king g2
bishop captures on c4 king f3 they will
try to escort
those pawns up the board but it's easier
said than done just bishop b2
king e4 now comes bishop captures an a3
king d4 and after bishop to e6
it was in this position that the entire
cloud9 team
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here
so uh extremely impressive showing by uh
by
all of them uh here as i had to redo
this video something was off with the
sound i don't know if i already shown
this
uh photo but yeah this is uh how they
were playing andrew was uh
blindfolded in his own home of course
and they were
using some sort of a huge microsoft
monitor to
uh to you know the input to the move so
it was a
very very enjoyable i watched their
entire video it takes them 24 minutes so
if you want to check it out
i will put a link to it in the
description below it's uh it's very
enjoyable like i said they're
laughing a lot you know you can hear
their thoughts their ideas
and also some very instructive uh ideas
from from andrew tang
also so that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it thank you thank you uh
very much for recommending such a nice
game i did i don't think i'd see it if
you guys
haven't recommended it to me and as i'm
doing the morphe's blindfold
simultaneous exhibition
currently i thought another blindfold uh
exhibition would you know going uh going
very nicely
uh so yeah uh that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
john anderson uh ilyan iliff simon
ashborn dalibor plastician joshua
astonix
elliot for contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world so thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day